hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast Res Publica proteins
therapeutic vulnerabilities presented by
Adrienne Cox PhD we're excited to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab risk and sponsored by
biotech knee bio technique corporation
is a leading developer and manufacturer
of high-quality purified proteins
notably cytokines and growth factors
antibodies immunoassays biologically
active small molecule compounds and
advanced cell Diagnostics in situ
hybridization of detection products
biotech knees products are integral
components of scientific investigations
and biological processes in the nature
and progress of specific diseases to
learn more about bio technique please
visit www.hp.com/recycle a bird's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits before I begin I
would like to remind everyone this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into box it
appears on the screen will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
finally if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know you're having a
problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce dr. Cox dr. Cox is chief of
the division of cancer research in the
department of radiation oncology at the
University of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill associate professor of Pharmacology
any member of the Lineberger
Comprehensive Cancer Center she directs
UNC Chapel Hill's NCI find a cancer cell
biology t32 training program dr. cox
serves on numerous internal
external mentoring committees and grant
review panels reviewing for the National
Cancer Institute and teen nonprofit
organizations she performed postdoctoral
studies at the La Jolla Cancer Research
Foundation
now the sanford burnham crevasse medical
Discovery Institute dr. Cox has been
involved in the study of RAF protein
since the discovery of their lipid
modification by Prandtl Asian publishing
were the hundred articles in
peer-reviewed journals and consulting or
deer's for numerous pharmaceutical
companies her research encompasses basic
science aspects of wrasse family
signaling and transformation and
translational aspects dr. Cox's
laboratory is a constituent of the rasp
synthetic lethal Network a component of
nci's rat initiative that seeks to
identify and target rats their cuticle
abilities for complete bio is done on
the labyrinth website please join me in
welcoming dr. Cox I will now turn the
presentation over to her thank you Judy
and welcome everyone as she said I'm
Adrienne Cox from the University of
North Carolina at Chapel Hill in the
United States and we're here to discuss
targeting rats which is sometimes known
as the beating heart of cancer so we
have several learning objectives today
the first is to understand why we want
to do anti rats their be in the first
place if we can identify ways to block
grass function how effective will that
be secondly we want to understand how
refs works what rest does to promote
cell growth and cancer maintenance and
then from there we want to identify rash
therapeutic vulnerabilities discuss a
little bit about how effectively we can
target each vulnerability today and a
little bit also about what the prospects
are for the future so several of the
slides that I will show you today can be
found in a review that my colleagues and
I wrote which you can retrieve from the
same page where you registered for this
webinar you can read this review for a
closer look at some of the complicated
models and for many citations of
relevant literature so we want to
identify therapeutic vulnerabilities of
rest uncle proteins because we're
confident that RAF's is a key cancer
driver and a validated anti-cancer drug
target how do we know this
so these tables show that oncogenic
grass mutations which
you're listed in red on the panels to
the left and green they're associated
with the most lethal cancers the top
three cancers of us deaths on the right
panel also listed in red and you'll
notice that they match Kairos mutation
frequency the numbers of these deaths
are the equivalent of a jumbo jet
crashing every day so that's a huge
impact but when we say rafts it's a
little more complicated than just that
one word for example there are three
human rafts genes HS and rafts and k
rafts and due to alternative splicing
these three rafts genes encode for rafts
due to be binding proteins that are
largely identical except for their C
terminal hypervariable regions or H VRS
which are shown in different colors on
your slide here and these are important
for targeting rafts to cellular
membranes so these similarities and
differences are evolutionarily conserved
which tells you that membrane targeting
is likely important for rafts function
and we'll get to that in a few minutes
another important difference among the
rafts proteins is that their uncle genic
versions are not distributed equally
among cancer types k rafts shown here in
blue is by far the most commonly mutated
rafts isoform in cancer and in
particular is the key isoform mutated in
those top three lethal solid cancers
that we just showed you in the previous
slide pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma
or Pedic colorectal cancer or CRC and
lung adenocarcinoma or L AC and contrast
and RAF shown in pink is the most common
RAF isoform mutated in melanomas and in
hematopoietic cancers such as acute
myeloid leukemia or AOL whereas a dress
is the most common RAF isoform mutated
in bladder and in head neck squamous
cell carcinomas it's important to
recognize these differences when
considering appropriate model systems to
test anti Rast drugs for cancer
treatment and for understanding which
patients might benefit from which
anti-cancer drugs anti rest drugs so and
inside the red box you'll notice in
particular that in pancreatic cancer is
essentially all KS all the time and
arguably among the many mutated genes k
raf stands out as the most prevalent and
therefore pancreatic cancer is arguably
the most KS addicted of any cancer but
that's correlative not causative so why
do I say it
the most addicted and in particular
chaos is the initiating event in a
series of genetic alterations that
result in pancreatic cancer so does it
still matter later
only if it's important for the
maintenance of the cancer would it be a
good drug target so for another way to
look at this if you consider the cancer
car you'll see that driver mutations
must confer some kind of advantage to
that cancer if the driver gets out of
the cancer car the car doesn't go
anymore so drivers are potential
therapeutic targets in contrast most of
the many mutations found in any given
cancer are just along for the ride if
they get out of the cancer car it will
still go as long as the driver is
present so these passenger mutations may
be potential biomarkers which are
critically important for precision
medicine but they're not therapeutic
targets so how do we know if rass is a
cancer driver and therefore a good drug
target itself an example of some
compelling data is shown here in a mouse
model of pancreatic cancer when
expression of mutated rats was turned
off after seven days marked in d7 on
your slide the tumor has shrunk
considerably as you can see in the top
MRI images marked by the yellow arrow
and was less metabolically active as you
can see in the bottom PET CT images look
for the asterisks further when RAF
expression was turned on and that's the
graph to the right with the red line the
mice died of their tumors
whereas when wrasse expression was
turned off the green line they survived
so this is pretty good evidence that KS
is a therapeutic vulnerability in this
disease next we want to know what does
rats do to make this happen so wrasse
proteins are critical transmitters of a
wide variety of diversity extracellular
signals into many different and
important biological activities and you
can see the diversity on your screen at
the top the plasma membrane so you can
easily imagine that normally the raf
signal must be tightly regulated in
order to transmit all these different
signals only when it's appropriate
one critical way that wrasse is
regulated is by binding to GDP or gtp in
the left panel you can see that wrasse
proteins are in the resting inactive or
off state when they're bound to GDP
they're active or on that's the green
light when they're bound to gtp there
are two critical parts of the RAF's
protein that change conformation when
bound to GDP versus gtp which you can
see here and it looks like the animation
is not working but if you envision your
you put your two hands together and you
flap your fingers back and forth the red
parts that are marked as switch 1 and
switch to completely change their
orientation we'll see this again the
switch 1 and switch 2 part in a few more
slides and you can imagine based on this
information that locking rafts on the
gdp-bound or off state would be a good
way to block wrasse activity and you can
also imagine that encouraging rafts to
be chronically GTP bound would be a good
way to continuously transmit signals and
thereby to cause problems and that's
what happens in cancer when wrasse is
oncogenic we mutated wrasse is
chronically bound to gtp and it's
signaling doesn't get turned on and off
properly it doesn't matter what the
input signal is however it's not enough
to be GTP bound and active to transmit
signals properly for example to promote
cell proliferation as shown in the
figure of a dividing cell at the bottom
left wrasse proteins must be anchored to
the plasma membrane and this is a
process that requires modification of
wrasse and the hvr by a farnesyl
isoprenoid lipid mark yosef in the
absence of this lipid anchor wrasse
cannot associate with membranes and it
doesn't function properly so you can
imagine that this might be a
vulnerability for wrasse as we'll
discuss in a moment
the problem with oncogenic lis mutated
rafts is that it's always active and
transmitted signals to its downstream
effector targets even when there's no
upstream stimulus shown here are two of
the most important rafts downstream
effectors signaling pathways the raft
mech or cascade or map kinase cascade
and the pi3 kinase Akt mTOR pathway note
that elements of these pathways are also
commonly aberrant in cancer largely but
not completely by somatic mutations and
as a brief aside in the several
developmental disorders known as wrasse
Sapa these names are listed in the box
germline mutations in each of the
components shown here can be responsible
for over at
of the same wrath map kinase pathway to
drive these recipe diseases so the key
thing here is too much upstream and put
too much downstream output hopefully by
now you're convinced that rasa is a well
validated target for cancer treatment
but as ray also druggable because both
of these things are important and
required if we actually want to make
anti arrest drugs so mutational e
activated rasa proteins were identified
in human cancers 35 years ago yet after
enormous effort and expense and numerous
attempts there are still no approved
aunt iris drugs what's the problem here
why is that the case
why have we failed to make anti reste
drugs so far there are many things that
have been done wrong that are very
important for us to understand so we can
do better going forward and the first
thing is we targeted the wrong rass
protein it turns out not all Rast
proteins are created equal we perform
the wrong clinical trials and when I say
we I mean we as a field as a whole we
have underestimated the complexities of
signal transduction we draw them as
simple linear pathways but they're
really linked in very complicated
networks we also underestimated the
limitations of RNA functional screens so
when we knock down rafts with AI RNA or
shRNA what happens and worst of all
possibly we did not sufficiently
anticipate the tremendous adaptability
of cancer cells once cells get addicted
to K RAF or 2n raster to HS and we hit
them with genetic or pharmacological
ways of blocking these rest proteins
these cancer cells are very wily and
they figure out how to get around it and
we'll see that again and again so what
should we do now this is a figure from
the linked resource that I mentioned at
the beginning let's systematically now
go through the different ways people
have tried to target the beating heart
of cancer some of you however may be
wondering at this point why do we need
all these different approaches why don't
we just target rest directly to turn it
off and the answer is at the moment we
can't do that yet so
active wrasse holds very tightly to gtp
and can sometimes be described as a
greasy ball that has no obvious pockets
for drugs to bind however new pockets
are being identified and new direct
binders are in preclinical development
now here are some examples of tool
compounds that bind grafts directly and
interfere with its function either by
blocking rafts activation by positive
regulators such as the rafts gift sauce
or by preventing rafts from transmitting
a downstream signal by activating its
effectors such as RAF and you'll notice
that the bottom three compounds are
indicated as blockers of a particular
rafts oncoprotein the g12c mutant the
initial idea here with compound 12 was
to take advantage of chemistry uniquely
possible due to the reactive cysteine in
this mutant analysis of newer compounds
then showed something really interesting
if it been assumed that effective direct
Rass inhibitors should bind and impair
the ability of the active gtp-bound form
of the protein to signal to its
effectors so why does this table
indicate that these g12c specific
compounds block guest stimulation in
other words the formation of active GTP
bound rest so biochemical analysis has
unexpectedly shown that these compounds
preferentially bounding inactive
gdp-bound form of rasty 12c and
structural analysis shown here then
revealed but as an example ARS 853 bound
rafts g12c in an allosteric pocket under
the switch to region that was not
present in the active gtp-bound form and
look at the red arrows at the in the
image at the right of the model you can
see how the irreversible covalent
binding of Eris 853 would block sauce
one from getting in there to promote the
release of GDP and the subsequent
binding of gtp these findings of course
lead to many questions there's hope that
this kind of approach can be refined to
generate a compound that has both this
mechanism and also desirable drug
properties rather than the low
micromolar potency seen with eros 853
and because it prevents formation of GTP
bound RAF combining this and hip type of
inhibitor with those that block upstream
activation of rafts for example with
EGFR inhibitors
could be a more powerful approach than
either alone some of the questions of
course are can this approach result in a
real drug not just a tool compound how
selective 4ks would such a drug be with
this approach work for mutants other
than g12c what are the implications for
combining treatments and resistance
mechanisms so we've talked a little bit
about the idea of putting together two
drugs with different mechanisms of
action these are questions that are
ongoing in the field at the moment we
also know that these compounds are
highly selective for the g12c mutant
which is most frequently found in lung
adenocarcinoma is related to smoking but
other mutations are more common across
other cancer types as you can see from
this figure here and certainly it will
be crucial to identify ways of
interfering with g12 D G 12v mutations
and so forth so what are the prospects
for interfering and aspects of rats that
do not involve direct binders to rest
GTP arrest GDP we've already discussed
the critical importance of wrasse
membrane associations so we know that is
a vulnerability and the question now is
whether that vulnerability is
therapeutically targetable so now we're
at box number one and abyssion of
membrane Association in this overview
figure this model also taken from that
length resource shows that wrasse
membrane binding is not a simple
one-step process therefore there are
multiple points of interference the
first and obligate step is modification
of newly synthesized grass proteins by
farnesyl transferase or FTAs shown in
the figure
this finding set off a veritable
stampede of efforts to identify
inhibitors of FTAs which are called F T
is and you can see that in the red box
next to F th and at the bottom of the
figure so the goal and intent of
developing F T is anti Rast Arup
Eutychus was to prevent wrasse membrane
anchoring and thereby lead to cell death
due to loss of raft functions very
impressively in early in vivo
experiments farnesyltransferase
inhibitors or F T is were able to cause
rapid and durable regression of some
models of cancer the dramatic tumor
regression shown here in a mouse model
of HS induced breast cancer along with
no obvious systemic toxicity resulted in
widespread extreme enthusiasm and the
opening of numerous clinical trials of
ft is unfortunately many pharmaceutical
company executives decided that the
quickest route to FDA approval would be
by demonstrating efficacy and pancreatic
cancer a wrath driven disease with no
good therapeutic options which sounds
logical on its face except FG eyes are
not effective against human pancreatic
cancers and here's some examples of
publications indicating that that's the
case so why were they not effective and
should this have been a surprise no this
should not have been a surprise many
scientists were frustrated but not
surprised when these trials failed so
whenever there are unexpected results
it's important to think about what are
the alternative explanations that could
be responsible and in this case were
these disappointing clinical trial
results due to a bad target for example
were they do too bad drugs were they do
too bad trial designs or maybe all or
none of the above and by performing
experiments we could determine which is
the case so there have been early clues
that pancreatic cancer might not be the
best tumor type in which to evaluate
therapeutic efficacy of fbi's and in
this quote from dan van hoff the former
president of the American Association
for cancer research he said in a really
keynote speech that there are no bad
anti-cancer agents only bad clinical
trial designs that is if you want to
know whether a given drug hits its
target and is or is not efficacious
against that target you need to do the
right kind of trial and these clips from
publications done well before those
clinical trials showed that we already
knew that kay rafts and NRS and hrs were
different so what went wrong
first the early research focus on the
hrs isoform in cancer was a problem but
until the FT eyes came along nobody knew
about the existence of those important
difference
between HS and KS but significantly
impacted the applicability of ft is
second and the excitement surrounding
the realization that rasa protein
function absolutely required the
activity of farnesyltransferase it
became too easy to forget that this
enzyme has numerous other substrates and
that fti is while beautiful inhibitors
of FTAs are not direct inhibitors of
rass itself and then of course mice are
not small people and drug responses and
mouse models of cancer don't necessarily
predict responses and cancer patients so
what happens here is when ft is block
FTAs from modifying grass proteins
none of the subsequent modifications can
occur and unmodified proteins remain
cytosolic and not at membranes however
in the presence of ft is non
farnesylated k r s and n rest can serve
as substrates for related enzyme GG TS
one that attaches a slightly longer
lipid allowing rafts to proceed to
become membrane bound and biologically
active and only h rafts remains
unmodified and because k rafts and rafts
are far more prominent anchor proteins
than h RS this has large implications
for the analysis and use of ft is as
anti wrath era p unfortunately these
quotes from over a decade ago are still
pertinent today for example if you are a
mouse and you have cancer we can take
good care of you we are not might so how
can we do better given the vast
resources devoted to ft is the negative
clinical trial results were seen as a
debacle unfortunately unfortunately
setback anti res drug discovery by many
years eventually among the most
important lessons learned or re learned
was the importance of being able to
identify the model most appropriate to
the question even now although we know
about key differences in ft i
sensitivity between HS and k rafts and
the importance of determining the
relative addiction of each model to an f
CI vulnerable rafts isoform and although
there are now more tractable models of
care as driven cancers many questions
actually remain to identify fully
predictive and legit
we feasible preclinical models for drug
discovery efforts targeting this and
other therapeutic vulnerabilities of
rafts and almost any other drug target
really however there are still important
concepts to take away from these trials
first and foremost FCI's did not fail in
KS driven pancreatic cancers because
they're bad drugs or because chaos is a
bad target they failed because
inhibiting ftas does not functionally
inhibit k rafts however we know that h
stress is functionally inhibited which
begs the question our f TI is useful for
hrs mutant cancers not all hrs mutant
cancers are likely to benefit from F T
is for example hrs mutant bladder cancer
shown below in the red box tends to be
low-grade and treated efficaciously by
existing therapies however that's not
the case for head and neck squamous cell
carcinomas or h NS c c we're about 6
percent or more of patients harboring
hrs mutation accordingly one small
company cure oncology has initiated a
Phase two clinical trial and head and
neck squamous cell cancer is using
typifying have a very well validated fti
a couple of months ago they reported
promising results in a very small series
of patients however whether such results
are due to impairment of hrs function or
of some other f TI target is unknown to
help fill this gap we are currently
studying f TI target inhibition in HS
mutant head and neck squamous cell
carcinomas because we're strong
proponents of understanding the
mechanisms of targeted drug sensitivity
and resistance beyond ft is there are
numerous other examples of compounds
that can modulate
rass membrane association only some of
which are shown here however none of
these are truly specific for rats alone
so as with any experiments correct data
interpretation using these reagents
relies heavily on understanding what
their targets are what their selectivity
is and also how they function going
beyond inhibitors of membrane
association inhibitors of Wrath affect
your signaling shown as number 2 in this
box here are currently seen as the
therapeutic vulnerabilities most likely
to translate effectively in the clinic
in the relatively near future
one potentially daunting issue is the
sheer number of rasa fector pathways
several of which are shown here but
which effectors are critical in cancer
we can narrow these down for the moment
to the RAF mcGirk map kinase cascade I'm
a pi3 kinase Akt mTOR pathway the two
very well validated key driver pathways
in wrasse mutant cancer that we
mentioned earlier both of these pathways
are comprised of cases and are therefore
currently more tractable than gtp aces
given the importance of the rafts
rhythmic map kinase cascade numerous
clinical numerous small molecule kinase
inhibitors of mek have been investigated
in clinical trials as shown in the list
on the left and once b-raf mutations
were identified as key drivers of a
substantial proportion of melanomas raf
inhibitors were added several b raf and
MEK inhibitors have now been approved
for b raf mutant melanoma as with ft is
the b raf inhibitor vemurafenib produced
some dramatic early results which we'll
see in a moment and studies with
vemurafenib also revealed that attention
must be paid to raf ice to form
differences an inhibitors selective for
mutant b raf should not be used in
wrasse mutant cancers so pan-arab
selective inhibitors are now on the way
meanwhile a huge challenge is to
identify ways of making responses to map
kinase pathway inhibitors or indeed to
any target inhibitors more durable or
more long-lasting in this now classic
study a patient with metastatic melanoma
responded dramatically with near
complete regression of his B RAF
inhibitor sensitive subcutaneous tumors
only to see them come roaring back a few
weeks later when drug resistance arose
the b raf target was the critical driver
of this patient's cancer and that target
was successfully impaired so what
happened as we said if a given signaling
pathway is critical cancer cells create
ways to overcome the block and make the
connection under pressure from targeted
therapies they find ways to go around
the inhibited target either by joining
the same pathway at another node or by
overcoming their addiction to that
pathway by using a different route
altogether
in the case of RAF and MEK inhibitors
resistance arises by a multitude of
mechanisms that have in common the
reactivation of the downstream kinase
Kirk and this can happen due to bypass
of the RAF and mech nodes due to loss of
negative feedback or to up regulation of
upstream inputs such as receptor
tyrosine kinases or rtks
so for a long time most people assume
that inhibiting target sorry most
assumed that targeting a given pathway
at any node would be equivalent however
with repeated identification of mercury
activation downstream of RAF and mekin
abyssion it became broadly clear that a
new strategy was needed what's the
solution
Kirk inhibitors these and other akin
hibbett errs are now being pushed hard
these in the red box at the bottom in
hopes that they will overcome the
reactivation of a problem there is also
the hope that it might be more difficult
to restore or function given its
numerous downstream substrates versus
restoring the function of RAF or MEK
given that they have very focused
targets however there's no free lunch
and no magic bullet Eric and abyssion
also causes loss of negative feedback
signaling and Earth inhibitor resistance
does arise so resistance happens how do
we identify these mechanisms to be able
to overcome them identifying those
mechanisms is of course crucial in order
to understand how to overcome them and
current approaches to determining how
drug sensitivity is converted to
acquired drug resistance include
analysis of gene expression and the fuss
or proteome and cell lines or inpatients
before and after they're rendered drug
resistant by long-term exposure through
the drugs and by use of genetic loss or
gain of function screens as you can see
by the speckled pattern of red white and
blue across this panel of chaos mutant
PTAC cell lines in response to numerous
anti-cancer agents among the many
complexities revealed by such studies is
that these cell lines display a high
degree of heterogeneity in their drug
sensitivity or resistance responses the
good news is this heterogeneity is also
true in patients the bad news is that
this degree of
CLEC city makes it much more difficult
to identify commonalities across the
board
it definitely reinforces the need for
useful biomarkers to make personalized
medicine feasible so can we find a
common link can synthetic lethal
interaction addiction or dependency and
therefore a target a little
vulnerability synthetic lethal
interaction with rafts shown here in the
box mark number three are those which
cause impairment or deaths ie lethality
only when blocked together with or along
with blocking grass itself one goal of
identifying synthetic lethal x' is to
find new targets and another is to
increase selectivity for mutant rats
over wild-type thereby improving the
therapeutic window for the purposes of
this webinar all I'll say about this
subject now is that there's a focused
effort on finding such synthetic lethal
interact with rats
sponsored by the US National Cancer
Institute the rats synthetic lethal
network or RS Ln is composed of a hub of
the rafts initiative at the Frederick
National Lab for cancer research and of
several spokes
consisting of designated academic
laboratories and together we're taking
complementary approaches to the problem
of identifying RAF synthetic lethal
interacting chemical and by and genetic
chemical biology and genetic screens to
identify targets and drug response
modifiers and by determining more fully
the RAF interactome some of the emerging
results from these studies will be
reported at the second drafts initiative
symposium in frederick maryland this
December the last category of potential
rafts oncoprotein therapeutic
vulnerabilities is related to wrasse
driven metabolism this much simplified
yet still complicated picture of wrasse
driven metabolic pathways is shown in
the linked resource for many of us
perhaps a more accessible way to think
of these processes is obtaining energy
through sugar as shown by the Cookie
Monster recycling intracellular energy
sources by Auto Fuji or self eating as
shown by the dragon eating its own tail
and nutrients obtained by drinking
extracellular fluid has shown by the man
enjoying his bottled beverages
an important thing to realize is that
cancer cells undergo changes to their
metabolism that causes them to be much
more addicted to pathways that they were
not addicted to as normal cells so for
example the Warburg effect describing
the greater dependence on glycolysis
more formally the processes that we just
showed in pictures are glycolysis
glutamine use macropinocytosis and oto
Fuji tool compounds are available to
manipulate each of these processes with
varying degrees of selectivity and
varying degrees of characterization of
their mechanisms of action one of these
compounds Clerk Minh in the red box is a
drug that has long been approved for the
treatment of malaria and because of its
effect on metabolism is now being tested
in combination with chemo therapies and
targeted agents for cancer treatment in
general rash driven cancer metabolism is
a burgeoning area that's covered in
greater depth than the linked resource
and in references therein and it's also
an area that reminds us that the cancer
cells themselves are but one component
of the cancer as a whole so have we
identified wrath unka protein
therapeutic vulnerabilities yet yes even
if we're not directly targeting them but
there will never be one single magic
bullet anti wrath drug and cancer cells
will find ways to lose their addiction
to wrath I mentioned that cancer
metabolism reminds us that there are
potentially druggable vulnerabilities
beyond the cancer cell itself in
particular we should remember that chaos
induces inflammatory cytokines that act
on the stroma surrounding the tumor
cells and that chaos can induce immune
suppression that results in tumor cell
escape from killing by the immune system
so maybe we should drug both rafts and
the immune system and indeed there are
people who believe that immunotherapy
will take over anyway this is
particularly well documented in
pancreatic cancer where the same K rests
on two protein that drives the cancer
also causes a secretion of factors into
the stroma and into the circulation that
induce and
my Loyd derived suppressor cells these
cells shown and brown on the rate then
help the cancer cell count then help the
cancer escape from the immune system by
blocking cd8 positive killer T cells
that would otherwise be able to clear
the tumor cells the dragon grass is
predicted to have beneficial effects on
multiple levels
finally rats oncoproteins are also
involved in other druggable processes
linked to oncogene and tumor suppressor
function some examples are protein
degradation and DNA repair
how does wrasse participate in these
processes as one example K regulates
stability of the Mik hunka protein as
another wrasse regulates metabolic
changes that may induce sensitivity to
PARP inhibitors and lastly the rafts map
kinase pathway regulates the cell cycle
in part through protein degradation of
components that regulate it so
combinations of existing targeted
therapies may indirectly but effectively
impaired rafts oncoprotein functions as
well as the kinds of activities that
we've already talked about one
cautionary note is the extreme
complexity of the biological activities
of rats and other oncoproteins
these can be quite daunting some of you
may be daunted already but without going
into any of these issues specifically
let's simply point out that the better
we understand how rats oncoproteins work
the better we can predict test and
interfere with those functions to treat
R as driven diseases effectively so what
is the current thinking on drugging
graphs direct inhibitors may be coming
but they're not here yet no targeted
therapy will work as monotherapy
effective inhibition of a sector
signaling is likely to require
inhibition at multiple nodes either of
the same pathway for example if we put
together a raf inhibitor plus a MEK
inhibitor or RAF inhibitor plus an
orican hitter or of different pathways
so for example a Newark inhibitor plus
inhibitor X of course this brings up
issues of toxicity and there may be
greater toxicity by combining or there
may be less Texas
combining and of course the goal of drug
discovery efforts is to reduce toxicity
accordingly at the moment it's looking
like all roads lead to or through urk at
some point it's possible that metabolism
may be at the bottom of this cascade
more than anyone has appreciated
previously certainly targeted therapies
with or without immunotherapies will be
optimized only when we better understand
the biological complexities and we have
identified appropriate biomarkers to
track how well our drugs are blocking
them or not blocking those targets so is
wrasse really druggable yes but there
will not be one single anti Raths drug
that will work in all rasputin cancers
and cancer cells we'll find ways to lose
their addiction to wrath so we will need
to find ways to overcome whatever new
pathways they've decided to take so
thank you all for listening I'd like to
thank members of my lab my colleagues
and collaborators my co-authors on our
length resource and now I'm happy to
take your questions thank you dr. Cox
for that informative presentation it is
time for Q&A so if you have a question
you'd like to ask dr. Cox please do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
this end button well answer as many of
your questions as you have time for so
let's get started our first question is
why is rath considered undruggable yet
people are still going after it so the
reason that wrasse is still considered
undruggable is that there are no drugs
yet the reason people are still going
and the reason that specifically it came
to be called undruggable was because of
the many years that have gone by and the
many different effect attempts that
people have made to target it so when
many attempts have been made with no
success then people begin to think well
maybe it's not even possible in the
first place but the reason people are
still going after it is because there
are new openings new
compounds new ways of understanding
wrath and in particular when we used to
say that grass was a greasy ball with no
pockets at all for drug binding new
structures are coming out and new
compounds are coming out that let us see
that formerly cryptic pockets can be
exploited and new ways of identifying
how to get in there and perhaps to tweak
the size of those pockets or the
selectivity of those pockets are coming
online so there really is much greater
hope now that by understanding all these
different ways in which Raths works that
the new compounds can be applied in the
appropriate way at the appropriate time
so I believe there will be wrath drugs
we just don't know when yet will anti
wrath drugs need to be selective from
mutant crap yes we're very certain that
that effective and sufficiently
non-toxic drugs will absolutely need to
be selective for mutant wrath when we
say that we don't necessarily mean the
gtp-bound form of the mutant as you saw
there are some compounds that bind
selectively to the gdp-bound or inactive
form but they must bind to the mutant
and not to wild-type rats and the reason
for that is because grass is a
proto-oncogene in its normal state that
is it's required for so many functions
of the normal cell that blocking
wild-type rats completely is expected to
have serious deleterious effects when
will the first anti-rust road hit the
clinic everyone wants to know that and
no one knows the answer to that question
what outside-the-box approaches should
be considered that are currently being
ignored so at the moment people are
still thinking about kinases kinases
kinases they're still thinking about
they're still thinking too much I think
about the things that we are currently
working on what we might need to think
about more are for example everyone is
paying a lot of attention to the rafts
raft Network map kinase cascade
but people seem to stop once they get to
earth well has hundreds of substrates so
which of those are really important and
can we instead target those substrates
rather than targeting everything that
earth does so that kind of outside the
box approach I think would be important
on one of the slides previously we saw
that Nick for example was a key
substrate of oak and Nick of course is
another oncogene that's a transcription
factor that is currently also considered
undruggable although there are compounds
that do block mix function so I think
that paying more attention to the more
global ways in which Raths works would
be very beneficial and to more
thoroughly understanding components of
its network of activity other than the
classic linear pathways that we show in
our slides is important and finally I
think it's very important to think more
clearly about how the networks work and
perturb each other and the rest
synthetic glacial Network that's doing a
lot of investigation of how the rest
interact ohms work is really a key
approach to doing that quick targeting
of mutant rats with monoclonal
antibodies be a better solution than
conventional drugs so the point of
monoclonal antibodies is to get really
specific I think that certainly greater
specificity is important antibody of
course have different kinds of pros and
cons than targeted therapies one of
which is how do we avoid feedback
problems but yes I think there certainly
could be a value for that in the future
there are currently mono bodies that are
tool compounds that are out there that
may someday be able to be turned into
drugs as well so that was a great
question
well Empire a therapy suffer from the
same kinds of resistance mechanisms and
limitation
scene with other targeted therapies such
as kinase inhibitors Oh certainly we do
expect that so kinase inhibitors suffer
from resistance mechanisms that I
described whereby dependence on a
particular pathway is no longer the key
so for example when we have MEK
inhibitors the resistance that arises is
let's just go around MEK let's go to irk
instead and reactivate downstream
similarly with Raph
similarly with Kirk that there are just
different ways of getting to the same
place or even not being addicted anyway
there are several published studies that
say for example that the transcriptional
coactivator and Meccano transduction
sensor Yap one is one way that
pancreatic cancer colon cancer and other
types of cancer cells can get around
being addicted to K rass by upregulating
Yap one and whether that is true for
every function is unlikely whether
that's the only thing is certainly not
the case even some of those studies that
showed the importance of Yap one as a
potential rescue target also showed you
know about a hundred and fifty other
different ways in which rasa addiction
could be rescued and so we have no
reason to think that there is any way
that any targeted therapy will ever be
able to avoid those kinds of resistance
mechanisms as as other questions may be
coming in I think right now will also
give you a chance to close and we can
always jump back so I would like to once
again to thank dr. Cox for her
presentation do you have any final
comments so I just want to say that I
thank you all for listening that this is
certainly a complicated area I've tried
to hit just some of the highlights if
people have questions that they would
like to send afterwards by email I'll be
happy to try to get to those as many of
those as I can and that I hope we wish
you all who are studying rats the best
of luck
and hope that the targeting of wrath
will be coming to fruition sooner rather
than later so thank you all for
listening that's all I have to say for
now thank you and additional questions
give the answer by email of course so
thank you once again I would also like
to thank our sponsor biotech me for
making today's educational webcast
possible this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the CC button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits before
we go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's like event
that is all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye